uh we got the Jew tunnels so basically
what happens in Brooklyn the kabad hidic
Jews are basically creating a tunnel
system that connect synagogues it's like
two giant two synagogues connected into
one on one block that they connected to
like a woman's like ritual bath place
that's abandon you have to put ritual in
there that that's how I know you a
little anti-semitic you just throwing in
little like ritual like a like a blood
liel kind of spot where they bathe in
blood I'm pretty sure under the ground
that's what I read ritual is crazy cuz
you could have just said bath but it's
not a bath place it's like do it for
like cleans rual yeah sacrifices it's
not just like a bath house it's like a
ritual place where they go do religious
ceremonies there's a place you can send
your [__] when she's on a period That's
What It Is bro what is it mcka that's
why they're building Tunnels for this
[__] purified yes like open that [__]
back up low key they doing they doing
the neighborhood of service yeah and New
York City is shutting them down they
literally have a layer that they could
keep perioded women for that week to
stop ruining the community they're doing
the community a service imagine what
that person who's just selling fresh
Hala on a Monday has to deal with when
he's got a mom of 17 with 14 different
strollers pushing it down the street she
needs to get her fresh holla and she's
giving him all the attitude cuz she's
just bleeding like a faucet what should
she do what what should you do with her
you put her underground for one week you
put her underground you keep her there
okay you can feed them you can give them
water you can give them all the
Necessities like a Mr Beast video
exactly ex what is Mr Beast even doing
it's been a week he hasn't been
underground with 45 angry female Jews
dripping blood oh man that is a great
video Jimmy get on it yeah that's a
video dude Jimmy you got to go
underground with these [__] I can't
last that long that's it's an hour he's
like I'm out all I'm saying is if we get
that's why they're fighting the cops did
you see how hard they're fighting the
cops they're like go let my wife up
don't let her up she has three more days
CL I mean yeah this one is crazy Hil n
bro do not that's it do not let my wife
up you keep her down there yo send them
back to Israel yo that's great look at
my mans so this like a zombie
horde what yo what was what's that
movie World War Z World War yeah this
world J dude yeah I mean imagine a
zombie horde of hidic juice holy [__]
someone bring out a strip of bacon to
pause that [__] immediately that's like
vampire's garlic bro hold it up they
should have done that actually these are
the extremist the crazy part is no one
got in serious trouble just a couple of
fines couple of misdemeanors like
they're pushing the cops I mean they
gonna be in trouble when they got to
deal with their wife for the next three
[__] days and if you notice every
mattress they brought out was soaked
with red blood why is that M cuz that's
where they put them this is a period
Center this is a fantastic idea I don't
see a single woman I don't see a single
woman this where the extremists were
trying to find their own other prayer
room and they use an abandoned Mikvah to
do so and I say those extremists toss
them out I don't like that you call
extremist why is it extreme I like you
call them extremist what why is building
a tunnel
extreme wait wait I feel like you're
setting him up for something that's not
set up here at all I feel like you're
[__] set upem my dick on you whatever
no why
is why is put that back on him put that
back let him apologize for
that do replay now I understand why your
dad was upset yo now I understand it was
J like that coming out I feel unfor I
wasn't doing it right big what was that
no no you gave him a big I gave I
actually don't understand why is this
extremism to build a tunnel to a thing
like it might be unsafe but why is it
extreme I think it's for a small little
group and they're separ your son you got
him to hate Jews for at least a minute
your Victory bro I'm genuinely take your
Victory we should all you turned him
against his
people we should all hate we should all
sacrifice
ask ask you know what are now you the
the the Palestinians in front of the
Holland Tunnel you went too far too far
y'all went too far we all got to
sacrifice a couple
percent
now
SE tunel
now that [__] slaps that's a Kanye song
right there all right so Dove hates Jews
moving
on Yo listen shout out to kabad laich
thank you for always trying to wish me
happy Hanukkah already tweeted thanking
the NYPD for helping them see shout out
to laic y'all know what you doing man
you know how they found them how they
found out the tunnel existed a cheese
trap
wait wait wait wait I say come on I just
wonder how does it come so quick how
does that come so quick that's a little
racist that it comes that quick for you
dude why why do you have that just in
the chamber I don't know maybe I'm a
[__] detective maybe that's maybe I'm
Axel Foley maybe you got real life Axel
Foley in front of you right now you need
to
appreciate come on say top me on the
racism miles can't wait to get in Miles
cannot wait to get in his ears are
come here coach was Great Mouse
Detective but I said Great Mouse
Detective [__] miles it only works
for
black you can go to priz pick.com use
the promo code Schultz SZ you're going
to get a 100% deposit match up to
$100 think about that okay you put in a
100 their match with 100 then you go get
your prize picks on make sure you go to
prize picks.com use that promo code
Schultz
let's get back to the show